and we are live welcome to the iron
Lords podcast episode number 30 and it's
another glorious Sunday and we are back
at the roundtable on the Lord's Day also
debuting our brand new NFL friendly time
11:00 a.m. est I'm very excited about
our returning guests so we're gonna get
right into it I want to introduce the
Lord was no stranger to the ILP and it's
always supported us tingling since
breaking bread with this Lord is first
and foremost in introducing himself in
the kitchen thank you very much anybody
to check his to it I'm telling you made
it new feta cheese cakes it's a sight to
behold usual suspects at the round table
unfortunately my combs with the coat
most has been locked in the Seaver room
he's been the job as kept him hostage so
you won't be here maybe maybe get us
think out later we'll see if we get
light attic but of course we got our
most technical gaming Lord the solo
gamer who lives for the single player
selfish experience survey of Levias were
broke Illuminati mommy
Lord sovereign how we doing sir so
fantastic this week man much better than
last week that's for sure under the
table last week much but yeah it was
definitely a rough too many LeBlanc's we
got we got you out of a Selah sickness
man funny thing was afterwards like Lord
Maloney a shout-out to Lord Marlyn yes
and my wife you know they were fine they
were good how was only one who affected
so you know my wife god bless her she
Metis things like well okay we're not
going to ever again the XS gave the Lord
was a man of his convictions in the
premium experience beloved Lord King how
we doing sir
what's going on guys how's everything
well it seems like just sickness is
going around let give everybody an
update on sir Benjamin Johnson he has
pneumonia went to the vet yeah so he's
doing well he's on the mend so yesterday
he was really vocal hanging out you know
partying with the king so um but he's
taking his medicine so he's doing well
now um last night and combat sports
semana New Year's
oh man you pulled that one out UFC stand
up I know the main event didn't go high
y'all wanted it to go as far as Johnson
fighting but listen hey next time you
know stuff happens you know his opponent
couldn't get cleared to fight I'm not
well-versed on UFC so anybody can jump
anything you know and the press you
actually demand annuities do you the one
who knocked out
Ronde like she dispatched it right she's
my favorite fighter as far as female
fighters go and also in boxing
chocolatito the man they was talking
about him one time I was pound for pound
and I thought he was a fluff champion
turned out to be just that my man so
check b-side gave him the business and
the reason why I know his name cuz I
kept making jokes about his name call
him the Beast side of the album he was
giving him the high cheese doodle making
shots um it was ill it was it was a
great night combat force and I snuck my
destiny in between that oh and of course
one of the original iron Lords
the hunter who helped build the iron
Lords movement from the very beginning
mister hey do himself Bobby Lord zero
how we doing sir I'm pretty good homie
just been grinding in the ground don't
stop a sense Tuesday at midnight man and
I am tired want to give a quick
shout-out to the channel 5 clan for
being cool even other badasses are
getting level 2 already - very
impressive Wow - you were the pet
nightfall video get it today nice to see
of course we have family to the round
table the PC enthusiasts who moves like
sir and the 9 in these streets so we're
happy to see that when he appears in the
wild mr. bullets rain himself Bobby Lord
why how are you doing sir I'm doing good
man have how's everyone it's been that's
my bro right there I lost the day I was
impressed like and of course you know he
knew that game illness on the ILP not
telling you what you want to hear or
what you need here so before we get into
what the Lords are playing then y'all
know at night king oh the night king
that's true I should run with that
you're right you know you know most
likely oh that's me and although lordy
pontus is family to the round table a
lot of our tick family may be unfamiliar
with it so I want to first start off
with our audiences his video game system
is to be and what inspired that amazing
destiny YouTube channel so Lori balances
give me some of those early systems what
got you into gaming
Oh me I started all the way back on NES
so 8-bit Nintendo upstairs oh yeah back
as I go but I mean yeah game was like
that's where it was like either bought
or in it like Mario golf or whatever
just this little man I definitely got
into a plane things like Super Metroid
still one of my favorite games of all
time
Chrono Trigger I mean I've been playing
a lot so got PlayStation I've had most
of the consoles over time except
probably my buddy had Dreamcast so I
didn't get that one didn't last that
long but I've had Playstations Xboxes
Nintendo's Adam all so cover a lot of
gaming and usually try and keep up with
most nice oh you started from the NES
era I did well right my question is did
you go should use kind of stayed the
course with NES and Super NES or you
just still multi-platform even back then
I mean I was NES SNES n64 and then one
PlayStation 2 finally started to get I
didn't have a PlayStation 1 so I started
with Playstation 2 and I have the Xbox
and then at that point after that
apparel
animal god so the Saiga kids want to
know no no no Genesis it did you guys
can have your get that Sega fan base
back sleep what about the now tell us
about what prompted that amazing channel
because I call you the night for solace
you're the first person I've seen doing
night falls solo so like that was that
part of the inspiration or like just the
love of Destiny like what inspired the
ebon system YouTube channel I mean it
was more just from I mean wanted I took
a break from what I was doing for career
for a little while so I took a break and
wanted to see how that was gonna go and
then just the idea of things that I knew
I could at least accomplish and it was
the challenge because after a while in
Destiny we all get to the point where
unless you're just gonna start chirping
people and things like that you get to a
point where you kind of know most things
so it's hard to find a challenge after a
while because if you know the raids and
you have a good team even those you can
knock out really fast but a solo a
nightfall
depending on the modifiers can be a bit
of a challenge so really trying to break
those down and it was for people who
didn't always have others to play with
because we know it's not always
something that everybody has a group to
play with so me I played a lot all the
time and was trying to help many people
out and it's always nice to see the
comments on the channel and people are
like hey thinks videos those finally
able to knock out my first solo
nightfall those are really cool ones to
see oh it's just helping people out
giving them guides so I talk all the way
through my night falls so while I'm
actually trying to do this thing I'm
actually trying to have a cohesive
discussion of years where these people
are getting inner this is the type of
damage you want to do to the boss and it
really kind of break it down and get to
know the playthroughs really really well
so it was just my way to give the people
the information so if they were gonna
attempt it solo hopefully to have a
possible nice man you do a fantastic job
like I said I studied a lot of I learned
about your the void Walker builds
through you when he's doing prisoner
penalties but they're all kind of helped
and getting grenades scatters and oh man
it's such a fun build
no nothing manacles when oh nothing
manacles gotta build yeah that's just
too much fun when they finally through
daybreak in there towards the end of
Destiny one well you couldn't have much
more fun than that if it was a void burn
literally cuckoo and I want to bring it
back to the Lord's so we'll usually I
ask what the Lord's are playing so I'm
gonna ask it differently other than
destiny what I have the Lord through
play let's start with Lord sovereign
Mary rabbits last week and I really want
to play that too yeah yeah it's fire I
mean as me means someone who doesn't
play arts yes games I had a I figured if
this game was good it was gonna get me
into it I have a long-standing beef with
RTSs thanks to uh law kognito and past
Saturday's were relegated a game playing
and most the time you know sighs I'm
playing a wrestling the halo was
decadent anything like that so every now
and again you derive it Lord cockney
those house and he'd be on the
PlayStation one controller with like
four guys huddled around playing
graphically it has to be and they
essentially folded my Saturday night I'm
going to get my checking on no at that
point in time it just wasn't food I
couldn't go through so my 15 minutes of
the session I'm passed out somewhere he
was pissed off with it because he like
he said he came to do the rest him in
the Tackett I hate it when y'all was
doing Madden XCOM I was like I'm into
this there's no
because we each individually
and you know again because I was doing
and I said you know I played I played
YouTube have you
yes I feel bad I'm gonna run through it
because okay so there's Warhammer don't
Donna War three oh yes and I picked up
blade and soul okay mm oh okay not
picked up Guild Wars 2 because a friend
a friend bought that for me and my
girlfriend and I picked up player on
those battlegrounds which is phenomenal
let's call chickadee Anna I had a I had
a friend pick me up a copy of Minecraft
yeah so I tried that like 10 minutes
then there's escape from tarkov which is
free those of you don't know this is pub
G on crack it's a Russian game it's
really early in its inception so it's
it's a it's like 40 bucks to pick it up
but it's it's well worth it if you're
really into like a survival shooter
where you could potentially sit in one
spot for three hours just trying to
fight you know have a fire fight with
someone let's see other than that oh
that's yeah I'm impressed
and the bouncer should I dare ask
anything else other than destiny too
since Tuesday no honestly a couple of
things you guys mention though like pub
G player and owns battlegrounds have
been playing that a teasing about before
it came out and then I've got to dig in
Mario Plus rabbits as soon as I get a
break yeah I definitely want to play
Mario Plus rabbits because it looks a
lot of fun so yeah it's real fun y'all
it's real fun real quick for me the only
thing it's other than destiny when I'm
not home playing destiny it's a good
switch so it's a which goes the marital
Rapids but a shout-out to uh Lord
McQueen you look high by two I've just
got this addiction to splatoon too and
it just started out of nowhere like I
think I actually shout out to a Lord
Lord is he started it and um yeah like I
was just cleaning once you get past
level three or four like everything
opens up and it starts like this game
was kind of deep with
cause I was really getting into it's
getting a little competition poppin mess
or Twitter she loves sending little
screenshots won't kill me old voice I
was fantastic on Xbox Live Oh talking
about what you were doing because
discard all the other services I can
communicate with my friends let's real
quick with results our last week's poll
results are in people have spoken to the
question when new titles are announced
and Xbox one X game specs are revealed
to not hit a four case it's the frames
per second target will you subject the
most blame the winner at 55% strong
laser close and controversial call the
people blame Xbox for all that most
powerful console / uncompromised 4k talk
in a very very close second place that
45% was the lazy developers a bad / bad
optimistic optimization group so uh
thanks everybody who participated in the
poll Twitter was going at it what do the
Lord's think about these results well
i'ma jump in real quick Lord I'll rant
rant oh the man with the million he
posted something yesterday and I have to
give him all the credit in the world
because I didn't notice he said a guy at
Microsoft or work a fan of quantum break
did the patch for quantum break with the
4k by his self
it wasn't sanctioned by Microsoft he did
it on the side so yes so when one person
could sit there and do it on the side
yeah default past ally with Microsoft if
they're not imposing this and putting
you know their best text on and on on
the games to get these 4k patches and
get them up and running and get it out
the door so yeah it was it was it was
definitely current version curious real
quick or lost solve your feel or nose
and 3000 we have discussions in the past
about that again I always say that I
would never call it developer lazy I
mean a developer is always going to try
to put their best foot forward when it
comes to you know how the game looks and
runs and it's you know a lot of it it's
gonna have to be in the console
manufacturer aside to give them that
help especially with the X so I mean
it's something that again it has to lie
with Microsoft and it's something that
we talked about when we first learn
about the specs how it was gonna be of
upgrade in games we said well I felt
that Microsoft was this was gonna be
something that was didn't even have to
be a you know stated the fact that they
would help as much as they can to make
sure that all those names would be up to
par even if the developer wasn't able to
do it because the fact of the matter is
that's how you push a narrative of what
that system is and so they need to do
they need to do it and if it's not being
done on every third party game they need
to figure a way to do it because that's
you know you know if you're gonna push
this narrative with the X that it's
gonna be the best place to play all your
third-party stuff you really need to
make sure all of those older games are
running as well as they possibly can
effects and real quick oh lordy pontus
was curious about Europe and I know you
weren't there for the initial question
but um did you did you question a lot of
Xbox one X Games get announced and you
know initially you know some of them are
not hitting either the four king native
or the 60 frames-per-second target um
you know the question was who do you
most blame because there was a lot of a
lot of discussion in the Twitterverse
you know a lot of people like hey these
developers are lazy in optimizing the
system you know and other people were
like no you know it's not that it's
Microsoft you know far from making you
know these statements that it's the most
powerful console ever you know yadda
yadda yadda so that what the call was
pretty much about so based on that
limiting based on that gave me a
complete discussion and have a great
insight into this wonderful it's new for
like Xbox one x is new I don't know how
long Deb kids have been out there and
things like that but any game that might
be announced in a release to be coming
soon outside something
like in house for Forza they're gonna
have access to that dev kit and the idea
of what's gonna happen before so they're
gonna have it running for capture and
Forza is a really optimized game anyway
but for third parties they're getting
into a little born their want to make
sure their game runs well on a larger
player base probably first and focusing
on the X so it was like yeah the push
probably doesn't need to come from
Microsoft to make sure it does but again
as its this early into the release not
everything is gonna have that push quite
as upfront
unless Microsoft gave them that stuff
four years ago when they started making
the game so my guess would be I was like
I feel like you guys are probably not
too far it's like Xbox needs to make
sure and Microsoft I should say needs to
make that push if they really want that
to be one you guys said it right if they
want this to be like the narrative
behind their platform then it's the best
way they need to do everything in their
power to make sure it is so I kind of
agree with that one actually three oh
which one you guys said that book that
was a play on this too long we got a lot
to talk about and it's a big show so um
we're gonna move on so we're gonna get
into these topics and of course my
brother from another mother
Lord addict he is not with us but we're
gonna rock with his topic and obviously
it has been the Lord of Destiny to this
week and we've got a lot to talk about
so first um when I get into our overall
impressions you know um we want to get
into you know what we enjoy about it so
far and um obviously we're gonna we're
gonna talk story we're not gonna get too
crazy because obviously it's a couple of
Lords with not completed the campaign I
believe Lord SWAT and Lord sovereign but
um we want to discuss a little bit about
that so I want to give it to Lordy bonds
who's first
destiny to the release it's finally here
we waited all this time one of our
favorite games
talk to me Lord about this how you
feeling about it uh well I haven't
stopped playing it pretty much unless
I've been outside of work so my wife has
probably loved me for that but I told
her many times in advance so it's like
using she's been pretty cool about it no
honestly it's been amazing I mean the
fact that I'll just edit the menu screen
and kind of forget that I'm staring at
the menu screen and listen to the
soundtrack alone it's amazing
so good the sound design for the guns
the abilities the jumps the grenades
everything is really really well
just taken to the next level I mean they
took a sequel and stuff that wasn't
already good they kicked it up a notch
when it wasn't even necessary in those
pieces the story is cohesive we'll get
into some of that stuff later but I do
think like it's not the vagary that was
vanilla destiny
so there is a comprehension
understanding us to at least what
happens in the story you're aware that
was there things I wish there was more
of sure but we'll get into that as we go
around the room the worlds have been
they're unique they're big they're a lot
bigger than I thought
there's a lot more to them especially if
you go for all the lost sectors and
things like that there's a lot more
experience lore each one even though
that's why I like going to lost sectors
because you'll go down and find almost
like a completely new texture palette in
a place that's not where it's supposed
to be which is kind of cool
the challenge is the gear the
progression so far we'll save your topic
about getting all colorful for the next
we'll be coming late and it looks like
we have stuff to save like I haven't
like I have enjoyed I don't wanna steal
everything I can sit here and talk for
entire two hours so I'm like I'm really
enjoying it I'll let you guys jump in
and say what you guys are gonna say but
so far I mean two thumbs up for me I'm
not a tough critic on this one it's not
perfect by any means but I mean for a
sequel to make just about everything
better
yes so whoever wants to go next I'm sure
we'll keep talking let's get looking in
here as far as you know being a day one
destiny
one player um vanilla destiny I didn't
even remember when that became a thing I
guess after the dlc and people was
excluded from playing certain activities
with their friends and you know I knew
in the beginning the first destiny was
held back from the old systems and this
show this oh man oh man the vision like
the first time I saw the hive in part
two I said oh this is how they really
wanted them to look because instead of
them looking like
skeletons come to life no it's actual
bone armor on top of them so when I saw
that I said okay and then the movement
of the Fallen the scurrying across the
floor stand up in Russian yes exactly it
this is what I'm what I was trying to
say like in the beginning when you're
playing by yourself you have the
headphones on the in a darkened the
feeling is of a del toral horror film
mmm and I said wow they nailed it
perfectly the story cutscenes leading
into it brought you closer to the story
I was like oh this is deeper way deeper
they had enough time to focus on all
faults and you know rectify you know any
graphical problems that they was having
before the 30 frames per second versus
the 60 frames per second will always be
an argument but I know why they had to
do such things that's because they're
being held back by the current based
systems the current based systems aren't
as limiting as the older systems because
that what was the the cache was was 512
megabits
cache that they had to work around
opposed to now the cache is a lot higher
that they can pull with the textures and
everything so the world looks tight
first you you see the foliage that's
what blew me away when I went to each
zone and each song and each world had a
life of its own it was fantastic for me
yes that uniqueness then my biggest
problems before is we needed an app to
find out when public events was
happening yes the fact that the public
events right now is a schedule thing
that I fly from n listen fast traveling
is a god-sent be to when you get your
scooter and the scooter controls is
fantastic they got tighter you can take
those corners because now the world the
geometric the geometry of the world is
so open and it's so diverse that the
control of the bike is better so you can
take those corners and dip and turn and
slide and go on the is I'm in love with
the game I know you can hear it in my
voice and I'll be waiting for the raid
I'm actually 17 now right yes any
streets and I got a couple of tricks
down down pack so I'm gonna take Lord
sovereign under the wing that story um
you know we're gonna appreciate this
game together loss of him because he's
because that's the one like you really
initially towards the end of vanilla for
it like day one and I also want to add
pose this question to you when you're
getting after you give you impressions I
want you to pose this question to chat
made a good point they want to know I
want to know your feeling specifically
about the main protagonist not being
speaking Lord Chief Tom isn't anyone to
know our feeling about that so I was
curious also how you felt about that so
first your impressions um well as
somebody who fell off with vanilla
destiny you pretty early you know pretty
early on I'm impressed with it I'm
pretty hooked on it to be honest so you
can keep your walking papers Lord anchor
thank you very much yeah honestly I mean
I think the game improves on on even the
best aspects of destiny one obviously
the story is been more fleshed out um
it's still you know a little over the
top kind of pop corny stuff I'm gonna be
honest I love I love I love being its
Titan because you know I'm gonna be
Captain America France although the
Sentinels subclass I love that um you
know what um but again like Zavala Kade
I can't release I can't stand honestly
because Cait it's just Nate is Nathan
Fillion like Nathan Fillion plays the
same role in everything that he does
same thing that already glanced
is the same in everything that he does
it's the same person so it's just like
whatever honestly the most the coolest
character in the campaign for me is
Dominic all to be honest yeah he's like
eroded out yeah roided-out you know hey
low grunt mixed with like Darth Vader
absolutely has some Bane in there so
like what I wanted from them is like the
smaller character moments that woman is
beginning of the game when he's talking
to his right-hand man and telling him
how his victory is also you know he
shares it with him and it was like a
very cool conversation with them I said
okay they get it they get that the that
the story is gonna resonate when you
have like these smaller moments and
especially which are antagonists that
you give him a real reason for and not
just being purely evil for the sake of
being evil it makes them that much more
interesting so that that hooked me very
quickly on the gameplay again the best
shooting in the business that really is
you can't really say much else about
that the gunplay mechanics are fantastic
and the game runs beautifully like a
Bonta set like the worlds are really
varied I've only been I've only got
enough up until Titan I haven't seen
anything beyond that but everything I've
seen so far like especially like the EDC
when I first got there it gave me like
this this Last of Us live like this land
was my shoutouts and I made devran
Church it just and the fact honestly I'm
a little pissed off there's no HDR at
launch because these set pieces these
settings benefit yeah it would look
fantastic especially when you go
underground and you have a lot of that
you know light versus dark you have a
lot of total with leg why is devran from
the EDG races
because you liked seeing crumpets
oh really disrespecting my falling oh
yeah honestly to be perfectly honest I
mean I'm excited to see what's coming up
I'm I probably won't be raid ready by
about Wednesday but hopefully by the end
of next week I'll be there and that
that's what I really want experience cuz
I never did any of that in a nest anyone
I never got to do any of that
I honestly didn't really get to do any
strikes either so I want to get into
that stuff I try to finish the story as
quickly as I possibly can well I got you
what I mean I mean you see me talk about
coming from the single player selfish
experience that lots of it is that yeah
also asking Lord
zero of next week that's improvement in
every way whatsoever on does anyone far
better and I say that somebody who you
know adored the first game to death
you know I played it that's pretty much
until you know they were like hey that's
nature's coming out and then as the
Lords now I kind of took a break so I
can you know get not so burnt out on the
whole idea of the franchise until this
came out so you know all that's
refreshed when I came in and my god this
game is it's so good it's blowing me
away really I think I think the fact
that I'm like pushing 280 light right
now kind of says that it's like listen
to the passion in Lord but was there
right now because I just want to jump in
a little bit on your point that I felt
as a destiny guy who's been there from
the very beginning um to me just loading
it up and getting those moments of wait
not only did it doc you made when I did
it who is in my fireteam you don't say
looking at me you and tomato squad from
the chrono radio come and sit in the
corner ready for this rate you know
because vanilla like people don't know
you know destiny I was kind of turn cool
for me after I you know I didn't
understand how the end game was yeah
shout the more sinister shout the Lord
King they were like listen man you got
to do your first-rate you know and we
did it in completed it and I was just
like wow so just to see those moments
relived
I thought was such a special touch it
was so bad it was like let me tell you
something about like destiny will judge
you as a fashion judging community right
blues and all my war on Iran and these
guys got you know like beyond nemesis
and you know saint-14 help me know so
I'm feeling better they're like so what
is your friend had like they asked Lord
King like what is lucky and I'm like
don't even look at my load up alright
get the free stuff and I'm like listen
there's no problem as long as you're
playing because I was I was cave day one
when that no cave happen I didn't do
anything else in the game I found the
loot cave by myself on some little side
stuff and I stood there for 12 hours
farming by myself Tilly fixing it I
farmed I didn't play any of the game I
was looking for Lou caves this time I'm
gonna tell you now
they sealed up all the holes got the
loot cave you just run into the dead
zone and you get a little you get that
little cash cash oh yeah pick up yes
loot cave it you're gonna get I'm sorry
look I did you the whole memories thing
hit kind of hard man because yeah excuse
me for what a lot of people don't know
firm well I mean they know what I mean I
get is for people who were there from
like the very beginning like the vast
majority of us you know that's that was
three years of dedication
I was just flash funny you know the
compliments and
like first is when I'm what the vault of
glass think came up right name like you
completed a Valda glass and for me it
was on launch day now sat there was like
well [ __ ] man you know that was so long
ago but I remember it like it was
yesterday because it was such a good
gaming memory right and then you look at
the people you did it with and I saw I
was like well damn and I still talk to
these people to real low the Lord like I
still keep a touch with those people you
know and very very very very very few
gameful yes you know connect people in
that kind of way and I don't like a few
hopin to I used to be like really big in
a multiplayer on and what was a halo
reach rate and there was a group of
people who I would get on there and you
know we would do multiplayer all the
time we didn't you know it was like a
different experience we don't you know
it wasn't like it was just a different
feeling altogether if that makes sense
leap because the thing is with the raid
it's like you have to have that
camaraderie and you have to you know
work together and be able to situation
or else you're just gonna have a
horrible horrible time right yeah so you
make friends doing it and it's and it's
a great experience
facts a shout out to Lord Frodo even you
know zero I mean II but think about this
real quick before I give it to you so
I'm talking about Oh take about what
that this game is done like I've never
seen a game that I've played for three
years plus right then made all these
amazing friends like a bet lordy bonta's
because of destiny how crazy is that
right we went to another state like
we're talking to each other and I'm like
I like this guy he knows his destiny and
we just kicked it you know it was it was
just a cool day and like I said I think
that the Kings fall raid for me with the
UM with Frodo I remember bonding with
him on hardmode when we finally did it
and I'm like yo you're in channel 5 it
felt like is so many people like you
have no idea like is something about
this game that's one as much as funny as
I used to be a hater of that speed no
one could tell me anything because I
spot you're up next
I think about what it did for us to bed
like all the stuff he used to do you
know say trials and lost why did she was
good I believe my feelings often have
that feeling because I remember seeing
when I was scrolling through him I could
see when I went all the time that I was
just solo playing not happening when to
play with and all of a sudden when I
when I started actually playing with you
guys and all of a sudden it's like it's
like crota and and you know taking King
and Oryx and all these different things
I'm seeing full parties built out I'm
like I know I really did play with those
guys a lot but I think one of the things
that really kind of stands out to me is
how they basically built themselves a
blank canvas for this you know they have
so much in there already but they have
so much that they can do and so so much
they can go into I think that it really
stands out for the testament of destiny
that
you know they're they're trying to build
something that they can that they can
work on and and expand on for years to
come and you know early I'm gonna be
very happy to have the ability of
playing on the Xbox and and the PC and
being able to kind of have that freedom
and to see just where the game is gonna
go I'm very excited for the time to come
with destiny - real quick before we move
into everyone's favorite topic I'm
[ __ ] me does anyone have a problem
with the main antagonist not speaking
just anyone know this reasons why he's
not speaking it's not like I hate a
little game where you're Master Chief
get your own entity and to go into
giving them a voice and doing all that
other stuff to it I think it will take
away and it will distract from the
actual core story I said I think and I
wonder and I've gone through some of
those moments where that Ghost chimes in
and honestly if you're guarding me and
even if there were like different
recordings whatever it is had some
camaraderie back and forth I feel like
you would even be attached more to the
game
if there was some type of discussion
back and forth when you sit there and
talk about failsafe and then later on if
you were just walking around and all of
a sudden there was a discussion between
you and him or if you're flying it just
actually really be curious to see if
they I know they won't from all the
things I've heard it's meant to be
you're your own Guardian so you're meant
to put your own thoughts in there but I
mean you think about Mass Effect on
something like that - where they have a
main character that you're gonna have
and it's full dialogue you've got the
Witcher same thing there's actual like
all those things already taken care of
so it's like yeah it doesn't take me out
of the world even more I just actually
feel like I know what that character
sounds like now so personally I would
actually like to see a voice in there
but I'm kind of with whoever was saying
that in chat I wish there were certain
times where I wish it was there because
there's some comments when you sit there
and back and forth it's like an opening
anything from the ghost it's like and if
I would just like say
sitting there like if I'm live on twitch
or something and I say something if my
Guardian said something there that would
be I feel like I get it has such a good
following out of I just always was I
chorus we're gonna just leave this for
those who have finished that can come
but try to do is non spoilery as
possible how do we feel about the
conclusion the ending and look at the
screen look at the screen and I must say
come back now the game is like three
days out it should be statute of
limitation bar go that's it
we happy with the oh I like is oh wow
this is the because you know yeah you're
right
that is a great parallel I said this is
the best villain ever and when he choked
out his man cuz it's messy yo I'm tired
of you gonna do it another way
no you kidding me
honestly that was when I stood up in
front of my television in class I said
this is the most beasties craziest do
that we've ever encountered other people
had a clear agenda his agenda he wanted
to be accepted by the light and he
looked at us as inferior beings and why
are we chosen spoilers through the game
today and he's gonna notice that really
I didn't give too much spoilers but I
get you knew he was gonna like I say
this I'll say this if it goes against
what you would normally expect from like
a sci-fi movie whatever where the good
guy wins it because against I'm good
like if gahl wins at the end yes give me
that you let him go good quick Lord
Ibanez
what was your overall impressions
absolutely try not to say too much here
were you please will you one more did
you know I was like honestly the
progression of Gaul was really really
cool as as you were saying just what the
character went through you actually got
to see development of a villain think
about so many of the Marvel movies it's
the one major thing wrong with so many
of them is a undeveloped of alone time
to put so many cutscenes in there so we
got to see the reasons why yeah the
motivation behind as opposed to the
vagary of who knows what but all I can
say no spoilers
there's a shape out in space yeah and
that's all basically all I can say is
when the game finishes it made me wonder
what comes next
yes yeah so I felt Marvel Cinematic
Universe yeah all I can say is oh wait
it we still waiting on the heart Queen
OH
Wow yeah between hive Queen down or
gather some big stuff out there
sorry no yeah I was just gonna say I
enjoyed it I probably made it harder
myself because there were some things I
didn't pick up in the final mission but
yeah we'll get to that when we talk
about spoilers I'm gonna jump in right
quickest I got I'll get a surprise you
are like I guess covered into this whole
situation obviously being a destiny fan
knowing always getting criticized what's
the thing people hate about destiny the
most well it has no story right all
destiny fancy at all time has no story
has no story so I came in with really
low expectations right
so as I'm playing it and gods like
walking and with how people telling me
that they finished it and they're like
oh my god right and I'm like oh so many
like the story the story oh my god oh my
god okay and I'm claiming it's very halo
s right I felt the campaign for a lot of
vibes from him which is I feel a good
day something that's good you know now
as I got in like okay I see what's going
on I will say I was a little
disappointed in how things wrapped up I
felt things kind of wrapped up a little
too quickly that just won more money
um once I got to the end all right I see
what they do here epilogue I see what's
going on okay but again I wasn't really
wow wow I was just like this is solid
right until I spoke to Maori Lord is I
got a shot where I'm going with this now
as you all know I am a disciple of our
sacks
so I never I was laughing during the
cinematics with all had the speaker
trapped though I'm like yeah get him to
the street like exhume did flash like
I'm all about that
about just know you've had that you know
ILP in the past Spock no zero Noi I do
not like any man it does not show his
face I don't have any respect for him to
me he's a false prophet I don't know we
spend like a straight two weeks trying
to decide on what is going on around the
speaker so all I'm gonna say is you
people like me who never really cared
after the game ends you go to a certain
place and you found out find out some
things about the fate of sin speaker so
my heart was like wow this is
interesting then all I would tell people
is to look at the state of the world
post int and look at how things are set
up look at how people of certain
factions are living very lavish ly and
all I would say is remember how destiny
one was set up remember where the
speaker's location was remember what
faction was next to speak and all I
gotta say for all my destiny what guys
with destiny - and you look at who you
think might benefit the most
if said speaker was gone that's all I
gotta say and if you put that theory
together you're going to laugh so hard
because certain people are benefiting
post I was very happy I'm very excited
about what's going on and also the
eventual which was already leaked the
curse of Osiris DLC that will be coming
in what you caught in the set so that's
my thoughts on it well zero that's right
you guys
I'll hop it quick for me yeah I felt
like the ending the cinematics and
everything for it I felt it's a little
let down I'll be honest with you I'm
with floor carnelian in the camp that it
was just too quick of ending um
the surprise at the end that I bought
this talked about with the space and and
while the ship there's the space the cat
dammit the shape and space guy Jesus
anyway that was amazing that honestly
left me a little breathless because it
was you know that was unexpected it was
cool I like that right but the rest of
her just the boss fight was also again
mediocre wasn't really anything you know
yeah I was able to sink that down by
myself in three one gunshots they want
nothing it was other than that the story
as you go through it is really really
good I feel like it was obviously as a
major appropriate way and um like Lord
anchor said in check you know rip the
grimoire because they finally got the
history and all that stuff going on in
game which is great is fantastic
I like how if you pay attention during
the strikes they mail tell like in many
stories inside of themselves and also
the Sabbath on song one teases future
things that could happen which is
fantastic I think that's something that
a lot of people sleep on because there's
a lot of history in that one if you know
like if you were one of those people
like myself a read the poem or you you
know that there's a plethora of ways
that that could you know come back in
there and in the future so with the
stories a little let down by that yeah
what is restricts the Sabbath in song
one couldn't we've exhausted that and we
wouldn't get this thing moving we got
still one couple more things to talk
about so when it mean it's everyone's
favorite topic
shader' gate come to the attention ready
streets were really buzzing that once
destiny to was launched and the shader
system was discovered and found out that
there was a slight tweak so as we know
in the past you know for those who are
new to destiny
you know shaders are something that you
kind of earned in the wild through
orangy you apply we change the color of
your complete outfit and now in destiny
to that has changed so what has happened
is we've been given the ability to now
customize each Island as opposed to the
whole outfit itself at one trader and
actually do that however it is now
consumable in one-time use and the
community went a little crazy in a
little while they were upset and you
know they felt that you know this is
something that shouldn't have change
they felt that on you know people very
upset as far as you know saying that now
they have to hold on the shaders and a
lot of stuff is orange eBay's that some
people are saying they're now gaining
shaders so I want to bring this to the
roundtable shader gate this and also the
actual aspect of microtransactions
also holding some shaders not saying
that you can't get them in the wild
during game but they are available
through our good friend Tess over at the
top so bring this to the lords anyone
could jump in but they would hate okay
I'll get my people are you think Luke
Smith said it pretty well and to sum it
up you guys are three days into the game
take a few seconds you're gonna get
plenty of shaders enjoy be quiet I'm
done okay okay bye to 30-ish late right
my goddamn inventory on my screen was
full of goddamn shaders okay people won
it okay
I'm at the point where my god damn vault
is full of shaders and my inventory is
full of [ __ ] absolutely there is no
reason people need something to hold on
to the hate on and if you're hating
shaders god bless you if you think about
it this is the worst thing that people
have come up with mean that's pretty
good that's what I said Louis why I said
as the people who hate it best be if
this is the outrage transactions calm
the hell down
when you live level 20 every time you
level up you can get all of that chip
for free I don't know how many times
I've got an exotic sparrow I've got a
legend area by the way small note of you
guys got any sparrows that instantly
load oh that is freaking way where and
it's just like instant going I was like
oh this is great that's like the Libby
let me play devil's advocate because I
got I got a defend little ink is honored
because he was it was big argument last
night whatever the lowest swat they're
good at it's kind of flow and have
material about to tear you apart shaders
on this match that is true like when you
get shaders you get them in bundles of
three or five or you don't want it I
want to play that was an advocate
because we had iron Lords Wheatley here
all aspects even stuff we don't agree
with you know he made a point last night
that saying look you understand that
there's more customization now but at
the same time you know destiny one
basically had this feature
and now in destiny - it's being taken
away so Lord ank is that anything you
also you wanna elaborate on your point
last night for a shader gate now I would
want to I'm not gonna be here this for
pretty firm in it no don't don't get it
twisted I'm not arguing that the
inherent action of making an item
consumables wrong or limiting an item in
terms of how much you get it but we need
to get a few things straight like a prop
but when I say bungee I'm referring to
Activision as well because at this point
they're indeterminable between two first
off the ability to bind a shader to an
individual piece of armor is not
mutually exclusive to the item being
consumable you can have both features
independent to each other what has
happened instead is Bungie is said oh
well we're gonna give you this cool
little feature but we're we're gonna
take away the aspect you like take it
away a little bit
so also like it in other games yes you
have other games that have like
consumable dyes and stuff but they
either have ways for you to make that or
you can either get guaranteed ways to
get those dyes in that kind of game it's
not solely limited to like an rng like
it's some games I guess I'm sure there's
some came out that I don't know about
that does that that guy he goes in my
next point and Bungie Activision mixture
of the two
took out this feature and he said we're
going to overhaul this but we're gonna
stick this little aspect in here to of
we're gonna create a whole new market
for our microtransactions that's the
whole point of this we're gonna say it's
consumable and like yeah yeah yeah you
might get the right drop you might get
the right dropper for your cerulean
divided shader which looks amazing with
that one they may then say oh you may
get that drop but you're only gonna get
three if you want more you can't buy
them necessarily because we don't know
yet until them the cycle of the week you
could buy individual ones like you can
try
now if you have bright pink grub dust
which you can get my friends down things
you got from bright engrams let's go
straight from the Dead Sea this is a
non-issue do you not see anything
[Laughter]
but a real quick so to to ankle before I
let the Lords respond my question is
since you've been playing on you can put
in some my house I see you out hitting
destined to streets how has your shader
acquisitions been have you not been able
to get a lot or how's it been far as
requiring change I have a bunch of
really crappy shaders I'm playing
destiny to you right now I will pull up
my little inventory here and I'll tell
you what I have in terms of shaders
shaders you want to delete like use it
to mark gear you want to delete you got
25 and that is spot to this old shady
game perspective in reference to other
mmo's in I believe destiny kinda maybe
having similarities are parallel in what
other animals are doing you're feeling
an air what's what
oh yeah I mean it's it's something I'm
very used to the idea that you know you
you maybe have to farm you know some
things to to make that that die and
sometimes there's you know there's a
little bit of a paywall and some you
know sometimes just a little bit of an
exclusivity to get in that die but you
want you know they there's always kind
of that mentality and mmo's especially
free-to-play MMO z-- yeah are very
heavily on that and that's t2
free-to-play oh not to be as expensive
as a game like wow
yeah yeah major games out there and what
I'm really just getting to is you know
you do have the option of getting them
for free it's just what it is I mean you
have to realize these are colors they're
not they're not you know imperative to
play in the game you don't have you
don't have to have all armor looking red
and black destiny one introduced that as
that way if you like alright okay one
question a lot about this letter
positive okay so imagine imagine destiny
one did not exist or it was completely
beta shaders were never an issue then
this is the first time shaders had ever
been introduced and this is how it was
brought to you what would you think
about that's until you got to deal with
like that that's the thing is the active
itself is not so bad this is the fact
that they took it away to sell it to you
and microtransactions to that point I
mean personally the shade of stuff to me
I haven't gotten far enough into it that
it matters that much of me I'll run
around looking like a rainbow I don't
really like this point I do have a few
shaders but it doesn't really matter
maybe as I get deeper into the game
it'll matter to me really how high
looking whatever and color-coordinating
now what you guys have to remember about
destiny one is it everything that came
out of destiny one post-launch was like
a Maricopa yeah they do bunch of stuff
because it's like hey I know we messed
up man we messed up here take this here
take this take this everything in the
subsequent three years after launch was
fixing all the been typically begins
when it came out so now guys at that
time honeymoon period is over it's to me
to down that I hi we got you we got some
recon again and we're coming out of the
gate hot you guys know who this I mean
this is only the beginning this is
the beginning you're gonna keep getting
crappy shaders and you're gonna pay for
the good ones and that's what's gonna
look I understand it destiny is not a
free-to-play game and that sort of model
applies mostly to free-to-play games but
this is again it's a massively
multiplayer online game at some point at
some point they're gonna look for a way
to more easily monetize maintaining that
game and they're gonna do it with
they're gonna do it with with physical
stuff with physical stuff that doesn't
necessarily affect gameplay that's how
they're gonna do it and little by little
more this stuff is gonna be behind a
paywall it's just coming because they're
gonna be like look man we gave you the
game you want it now you gotta pay up
right quick oh that's ah he's actually
made a good point and I'm just for the
record I don't want to make it seem like
I don't understand what you know thank
you miss talking about it's just as well
as things obviously shaders to me you
know they are important like let's be
honest their destiny is a fashion game
that's a big part game you walk in at
our level like okay you know say so I'm
not gonna sit there and minimize that it
is a huge part of the game in the
ecosystem but like loss of sense I do
feel that they know that they could
attempt to monetize this or at least put
this in a way that if you really want
and you fall to temptation and you
really let that if you want it now I
will say this to Lord zeros point I've
gotten a ton of shader since I've been
playing shaders are definitely something
that it's acquirable do normal gameplay
and I haven't felt like I mean I even
took a screenshot I was like maybe I
didn't finish the campaign yet and I'm
like wow I've got all these shaders now
the only thing I dislike and again this
is where I do so I went go on just this
point is that now I'm lower this time in
the mentality of if I get a hot shader
I'm kind of hurting it cuz I'm like wait
I don't wanna waste it like okay I gotta
hold it for my hottest
hottest gear you're that kind of it and
that's the only thing that it kind of
changed my mentality a little bit I
don't know how comfortable I am with VAT
aspect but I can't say that I'm not
getting shaders or having an abundance
of them they're just my mentality is
change so one thing is not to get you're
awfully let's just take a second and
think of the inverse right let's say you
got the shaders now and you kept them
permanently and then you still had the
freedom to apply them to anything you
wanted right like you do now but then it
the head unlimited uses okay now let's
say for instance that you know they're
brought back chatter wider fresh dank
from was for boolean divided right so
Leslie gets that and then you get it
again and again you could have gotten
quiet ripped off because you already
have it and it's like unlimited uses of
what are you gonna do with it to do is
uh you do what you do with the the
bright Ingram system like they've the
system is in the a already in the game
all I gotta do just make it that's
perfect if you free with the dust
imagine if they did this with overwatch
oh you got you got the Christmas skin oh
but you want to trigger and changes
something else well it's gone you can't
use it anymore that you can trade and
now keep in mind were you dismantle on
mod
all complaining for free
oh stop that stop that okay stop that
part right there I'm not gonna let you
keep running around with getting upset
cuz we don't got the shader you want to
put on your boots boots and no point in
time and that got a bunch of shaders and
no point and I look through them and no
point in time did I say I'm gonna
actually spend physical cash to buy some
shaders that's not gonna happen they're
not gonna get a dollar from me from that
ever at one point I don't care if they
come out with this
the silky blue I don't care if the
Patriots green I don't care I'm not
gonna buy it you know why because it
doesn't affect anything it's just really
for people who have OCD they have to
have their hat match their boots and it
got you now and you need that shader to
match the jacket and it's over you
messed up cuz every time a shader pops
up you're gonna be upset that that is
not the shader that you want and it's
gonna highlight all the problems you
have with that shader system I don't
have it because I don't need to match I
don't care if I have a green hair or
blue boots defense there's a lot thanks
for coming to bear appreciate you to
sight the good fight bed but let's put
it this way it's people like me that
destiny listen to in the first place cuz
I don't know that and it's people like
you who were on the fence with destiny
one and it's just great to see you guys
playing listening to and I think that
speaks volumes like a lot about like if
this is what the people are upset about
then I feel Bungie leases on the right
track as far as the game not being
come on every issue with destiny too is
self-inflicted Frankie listen to almost
every single thing everybody complained
about destiny one about and they
listened and they changed it but it's
the things that they cited like I will
change this we don't care that's really
rickety a point like it looks like
because of the reddit post went so viral
that our deeds I believe it was Dietrich
Osman when in community managers did
come out and say they are going to make
a some type of a change with an update
so they said they are here they didn't
say any specifics so I don't know if
that means orangey will get blessed but
apparently the your voice has been heard
so how about about this like let's just
see maker would you like be happy with
if they added something like let's say
legendary faders or exotic forgive me it
gives my my level 19 self a added an
unlimited user aspect of those would you
be happy yeah you know like this thing
the primary color is like a carbon fiber
[Music]
you did to you Microsoft having a row
deep problem I gotta say shout out the
monkey bar I'm really loving this guy
more and more
it's now for his UFC love and his boxing
hate um it's for the fact that he's our
guy on the inside man he's letting us
know little by little I guess you know
he gets in a lot of trouble I want to
tell him I appreciate you for getting in
trouble
Microsoft has put out the edict to let
all the developers know we're gonna
coach you up on putting mouse and
keyboard in now I've always been a
proponent for mouse and keyboard in a
Microsoft ecosystem well being that you
know they come from PC I thought it was
a natural progression that it would be
there I thought when I played Gears of
War on my xbox I was able to have the
opportunity to use a wireless keyboard
and mouse um and now that functionality
is becoming a reality with his latest
comments that he said that every
developer that is implementing this or
who wants to implement the control
scheme Microsoft will coach him up on
how to implement that and that would be
you know in a future patch and it's
coming yes so it's very imminent and I
wanted to know how everyone feels on
that because does it change the
landscape when it comes to competitive
gaming on the Xbox yeah this is good
this is good actually SWAT look at your
feeling on that first you're a PC
enthusiast so now that that's been
announced by Michael bar saying it's
coming what's your feeling on it
I was actually really happy because one
of one of the things that I would always
really love is that you know a long time
ago I used to send a lot of text text
messages between people and still a
little bit here and there but I would
always prefer a keyboard to have nough
sit there and scroll around on screen
[ __ ] and I hate the little
controllers ones because those are just
too damn small but but I do have to say
I can see a clear parallel with this
would come in come in too soon that
we're gonna be getting table G and quite
frankly one of the first things I
thought when I actually try to control
unplug G is I don't know if people on
the Xbox
going to be digging this with the
controller because it there's a lot of
situations where there's you know not
only a lot of controls that you have to
be able to you know be able punch down
and get through like almost instant and
you know it's it's a very quick game
when it comes to to dying no I think
that if I was a good victory management
I've heard as well like it's much easier
to kind of do inventory and stuff like
that PC as well yeah because you kind of
have to get into the mentality of of
moving while you're in your inventory if
you're not moving and in your inventory
you're more than likely gonna get one
shot by someone who can just you know
buckle down your head and no it's that
game there's no if you have like the
tier 3 helmet I think you'll get you
know maybe get an extra shot if they're
using some kind of like low caliber like
9 millimeter or something that that's a
really great distance but I mean the
game kind of runs it if they have like a
7-6 to sniper rifle and they hit you in
the head you're dead so it's kind of
there's no you just often see the little
game over screen just failure there's no
there's no what do you say like uh it's
not it's not very apologetic to your
death in that game so so overall loss
while you're in favor this move you had
you're excited in Microsoft's is being
aggressive with this very big the thing
is uh how many how many US beers are on
the Xbox one X yes I would say I would
say we definitely not are not big though
when it comes to gaming wired is the big
one because people don't like we're
gonna like the Bluetooth wireless when
it comes to video games and when they're
playing competitively because there's
always there's always just like the
latency that you'll see on on bigger TVs
even though we didn't see of wireless
probably some sort of hub or something
like that oh yeah I'm sure yeah I know
USB hubs are out there and that might be
I just I've never tried one on the Xbox
one I'm hoping that they work because
obviously you knows some like my
keyboard uses two USBs right you got
with it has premium experience that's
yeah mechanical with all the rows and
lights and no yeah there's so many
manufacturers out there for good
keyboards it's hard not to like yeah
I'll spend I'll drop 60 bucks on this I
mean really that's what I spent on some
type of additional support sneaky you
can get that let's keep this moving Lord
Ebonics how do you feel about this Xbox
keyboard and mice support coming I mean
honestly at some point where I figured
it was already gonna be pretty soon if
it wasn't already so they've already got
the adapters for it so honestly if it's
just you know approved by first party
I'm it's done correctly and therefore
there's no advantage and it makes it
even for everybody I'm fine with it
because I mean in the grand scheme if
you're gonna play on PC you know it's
going to be there and if you're not
using it might be at a disadvantage
advantage other way around I actually
like how Bungie did it where they give
the aim-assist back to those who are
using controller on PC if so if you want
to do it that way now they've got to
kind of figure out if we're using that
weird adapter where you get both but in
the grand scheme I think I'm okay with
it because as you said for something
like pub G playing that one enough on PC
I was really run wondering how that was
gonna work on a console I mean they did
really well with Diablo so I mean I know
it's possible to make like a console
port a lot better but in general I think
yeah it's gonna be fine the world will
survive zero
Mouse what do you feel yeah I think it's
really important that they're you know
they continue to blur that line between
what the what the X is and what a PC is
um and the fact that they're doing it on
the system level is great because it
you're gonna continue to have these
people who there's know how to talk
about creating a PC that can as powerful
as Xbox 1x for that same price range and
there's been a few people online
a Game Informer day attack and whatnot
somebody sort of challenged him to try
to build that and they haven't been able
to because you just can't it can't so
it's to me you really when you have that
when you have that console crowd and you
don't want them to leave in favor of a
PC well you create an environment where
they gonna you know where the Xbox
continues to be more and more like a PC
so the fact that they're doing this you
know on a system level across the board
hopefully you don't creating like you
know specific servers are not forever
for keyboard and mouse and in these
competitive games that sort of stuff I
mean it just adds value to the system um
the fact or the fact also that recently
there was kind of an uproar when the Age
of Empires got announced as inclusive
for PC and not coming to Xbox of people
arguing like wait a minute like you know
our stuff is cross-platform
but you know it doesn't work the other
way around around right so this would
help a lot in alleviating that and in
bringing hopefully bringing those games
over to the Xbox as well so yeah I mean
it's the fact that it's being done on a
system level and it's gonna be
controlled at that level that's what's
cool it's about it because that way you
know that you're not gonna have these
Wow you know some people have it some
people don't people playing it like you
said gee some people using it and some
people not using it like that sort of
stuff has to be controlled so I'm glad
they're they're taking a proactive like
approach to it yeah I mean pretty much
you know it wasn't nailed at I mean my
feels the same so good thing I love that
it's coming you know like Lois I've said
you know always thought the relationship
was a little one side as far as the Xbox
play anywhere kind of stuff and I think
this kind of stuff comes kind of bridges
the gap especially with the Age of
Empires announcement and things like
that it only comes um I want to say it's
not really a con it's just that because
the positive also about it is that you
know if there's a game like that then
that no online player base can get
expanded when you're doing cross play
right so you can include the PC crowd
and I like that the only thing they have
to be careful is with a game like Geo
maybe a lot of these first-person
shooter games maybe give the guys who
using controllers on console the option
whether or not they want to jump in with
the keyboard of miles
for us the lobby system just for my
competitive advantage so just gonna make
sure they have options you know I'm
saying because obviously you know
keyboard and mouse you know in the right
hands it's very dangerous competitively
so that was just my concern but oh well
it's a good thing you know I think it's
really really positive is a great topic
by looking and I'm glad to see shout to
Mike Ibarra he listens to the show you
know that these guys really are getting
in front of this and it's something
that's long overdue and it also sort
like I said softens that flow with Age
of Empires because I remember a lot I
think it facilitates the coming of World
of Warcraft it could be it could be
shout-out to uh largesse Gordon from
windows he's also thinking that you know
a lot of this relation is help making
Microsoft become a little bit more
friendly with valve a little bit more
friendly with steam and making them all
play nice together you know so opening
like the doors of cross-network play
he's got a great article right now
windows central shout out to just go and
shout out the ran and the Xbox too and
those guys talking about it recently and
yeah I think it's Microsoft willing to
play ball and I'm all about it long-term
vision is that you know I have no
problem with the cross play and again
ultimately I'm all about you know games
that have life and bigger lobbies and
bigger more people to play with that's
that that's what I'd add only in the
sake of time I know we got him we got a
couple chicks hop so we're gonna keep
moving football's approaching switch so
the state of the switch less than a year
from lease but going into its first fall
going up against the ps4 and yet box one
and ps4 Pro and Xbox one X so it's just
they're kind of in an interesting
position like we already know how Sony
and Microsoft are sort of attacking the
fall you know Sony is going to be
leaning on that third-party deals in
terms of saw
where you know it wouldn't test any call
of duty and battle for and obviously
their hardware bundles in association
with that they're not gonna have too
much in the way of first party support
you know you're gonna have the horizon
DLC and Gran Turismo and then Microsoft
sort of the same route you know
Microsoft is gonna be leaning on its on
its s hardware bundles on a third party
deals that it has like no shadow of war
and Assassin's Creed and they're gonna
have a little bit of first party support
where like Forza and cuphead and of
course pub G but a lot of the focus in
terms of like third party is gonna be
well okay the best you can be able to
play the best versions of your games if
you pick up an Xbox one X in terms of
third party but Nintendo's is kind of in
an interesting position you know is they
they have momentum going into the fall
you know with the success of Mario
rabbits the excitement over Odyssey and
and Xenoblade Chronicles even poke and
tournament you know stuff and coming out
later this month um but what I wanted to
find out from you guys that what do you
think they can keep up this this first
party release cadence you know after the
fall that's one of the things that they
have as a challenge moving forward after
this fall and into 2018 happy we can
assume they have a lot more first party
ports coming in terms of like Smash
Brothers are no toad treasure tracker
maybe Wind Waker HD stuff like that so
that's something that can keep them
moving forward in terms the first party
stuff um another thing that they have
sort of in their favorite moving forward
is a lot of these last gen ports that
have been recently announced that you
have the Resident Evil Revelations 1 & 2
coming later this year they just
announced la more coming coming to them
so that's that's also interesting I've
always said it that for me like give me
all of my mind at my 360 flash ps3 games
and last gen give me that entire
generation on the switch that I'll be
happy you know give me your bias or
collection or Mass Effect collection on
I know you when they bring me the old
stuff right if they're remaking
something like I say with LA noire right
there remastered
howling okay fine it's gonna be an HDR
gonna be crisper it's gonna be nicer but
it's not a remake I don't want that but
if I can get it on the go I'll get that
in pretty say again I didn't finish that
game so I'll finish it on a switch
that's what I'll do
so that's a positive generally that's
generally a positive they have right
beyond that also the Mindy's like
although all of their endings um I know
a lot of the ones that they initially
announced haven't come out yet but
they're coming and they and they fill
that void very nicely between big
Nintendo releases so they have that
moving forward now the challenges that
they have can be sort of crippling if
they don't get a hold to this like
obviously first and foremost the supply
challenges you know that they're always
there's always gonna be a rush of
systems in stores right before big
release you saw before Mario Rabbids
you're gonna see it before Odyssey and
Xenoblade it's gonna happen you know but
sometimes things that it's kind of slim
pickings in the in that time span
between those releases so that's
something that they have to address and
even Reggie hasn't really been clear
about what they think they'll be able to
do for the holidays so that's something
to think about and be worried about
obviously their online challenges
they're you know they they haven't been
able to get that stuff right the fact
that they've been you know holding out
on us and and they can actually do chat
but they don't watch who knows what
they're thinking is on that but that's
something that again as time moves on
it's gonna be more and more magnified
considering that they're not you know
they're not on the same level with the
two other first party manufacturers
right and another issue that was brought
to my attention not so long ago is this
issue which stories on the cartridges
and defer the Lord King on this one
because it's a very interesting topic
that doesn't make much sense it's kind
of effed up but I want to see I'm gonna
hear his take on this
I know it's coming I know it's coming I
know games gonna get bigger the Sturgis
will get smaller and you had to go how
to go buy a memory card all right let me
do this $85 all right so you do 280
files on the memory card and you
purchased the game brother you have
turned your game into a hundred and
forty five hours because okay we got
that to cake you ain't looking like this
but we got it we got it on the go go say
yeah yeah we're play-doh but Nintendo I
don't get that much storage okay well
you can't play inside the neighborhood
you don't get the neighborhood you get
you get you get the one basketball court
you play in the Phoenix Suns arena for
the rest of your life they're ours our
storage facilities was if you would like
to purchase extra storage you could go
we just partnered with SanDisk
so the prices across the street storage
bin over there and um we got the
neighborhood but we just part of this
whole thing is they tell me that I
purchased a physical game in the store
and don't have a memory card
said game way more balls question I do
um I think it's important that we
address be money is question in the chat
yes this question was my question about
the switches will consumer support the
third-party games such as FIFA MBA or
WWE 2k yeah I want to jump in on that
because I think that's a good point
and I know Lord King is anti the only
thing and I think for me it's paramount
that I know me person I'm going to
support it because I think that's always
been the Achilles heel
you know they had these great first
party games but it's like will third
parties jump on so when I see a Pfeiffer
and I see a 2k being you know ported
perfectly - you know obviously once
every 30 frames per second denoting that
was 60 but the fact that you know it's
so feature-rich Skyrim is you know the
same soul feature I'm gonna personally
support it because I want the third
parties to get on board you know yeah
like my thing is I don't want them to be
scared and be like look well no one
purchased you know Skyrim or no one
purchased LA noire or five yeah I mean
my thing is this actually Lord addict
tonight Boyka Basu in armor saw and we
was over the Nintendo mix and we checked
out the fight for that was like to be I
was expecting with Lord kings and other
was gonna be fight for go I'm like look
this is pretty impressive on the go you
know and I'm not even a soccer that like
that but I mean that that's what I got
it to load both be money space point you
know I think it's critical for you know
those games to do well you know on the
system and I think once they do that and
developers won't start you know dipping
their toe enemy below leg in make it a
little gaming you don't have the online
chat
you can't really talk to your friends is
gift gaming you pay a full price for a
gift game Nakamoto holder launching to
change the full version I know but it's
on the go that's it that's the sell of
the switch the portability you're
playing two K's of full version my
career my Park all that good stuff but
that's not a good thing
- talkin - your friends that's the one
place they need some help I don't know
how they're still so behind on the
online and chat it's just like they're
too afraid I think I think it's an issue
because they they kind of market to a
younger generation of gamers and say oh
hey we're gonna throw online chat in
we're now suddenly we don't have the
safety net of the ESRB and their rating
system it comes down to a lot of
different things but I mean obviously I
I liked discord I mean I know be said
that he's been using discord and that's
a big thing
you know I mean me my friends were
playing PC games were choosing to talk
about discord and quite frankly I mean
even when it comes to talking them in
general I'll usually pick discord like
so my friends from work that we gained
with even when we playing on consoles
were on discord so they don't want to
turn the switch into the new tender
that's what it is I agree I think this
is purposely done I know lordy but I
don't know if you heard that uh last I
LP there was a rumor as far as nothing
wrong but it was discovered if you did
it's cold during splatoon you can unlock
local voice chat which was kind of
blocked so I thought that was
interesting as far as you know Nintendo
these self-inflicted wounds of trying to
you know limit party chat do that stupid
app so I don't know if you got a chance
to catch dad about this no I'm you got a
chance to catch that one that's
interesting yeah it was discovered that
local chat is in there yeah do a code to
get it out and it was in the same room
grandfather Tendo purposely like lost
why say trying to like protect
from ourselves and it's that I mean I
can kind of see that for a little bit
just because I mean they are Nintendo
they've always had the they've always
had the family-friendly demographic at
heart and if somebody's like hey I'm
gonna buy this Zelda and Mario for my
kid and let him go out and they can all
of a sudden pop it and be like what are
they saying on there I mean it's an
intimate thing so I can understand why
they do it but there's got to be a way
for either parental controls or
something like that to be able to limit
like what you do and just be like okay
set this up put a password there is no
online chat no nothing but if you want
to have online chat we have a normal
feature set like every other damn person
out there it's just like why is that so
hard like Mario Cart if I wanna play
with my friend just like matchmaking oh
my god
like seriously just me and my buddy if
we want to play it's like it takes
pulling teeth luck and you know an
active play we were like you know
jumping in a room at the same time okay
I am okay cool let's chat lagging it
like it was all this extra step for no
reason yeah it's like that isn't
required so I mean it's like I love
Nintendo always have always well but man
get your [ __ ] together you guys stuff
it's gonna be interesting to see how
they handle this uh this cross-platform
thing with Minecraft and Xbox and using
Xbox Live servers and letting people cuz
if that works out and Nintendo doesn't
you know sort of get in the way and they
they sort of let those two ecosystems
work together then the line of
communication is open to kind of expand
that and use it in other ways like we're
just talking about no it's some point
out question the Minecraft thing is that
on the Java version like the actual like
the main game for the PC or is that only
on like the Windows 10 version that's
the app I'm thinking honestly I'm
thinking it's just Xbox I don't you know
I think it's an Xbox a yeah I think well
I think it's you know between even wait
what do you mean by it's an Xbox thing
like is it only for the Xbox
cross-platform it's like right so I'm
thinking it would it would be the
windows the Windows Store version of
Minecraft and Xbox okay yeah I'm not
sure about the Java version but that
said just open
that line of communication if if they
can get that to work without exciting
any in each other's way maybe you could
apply that to maybe fixing some of their
online infrastructure and like to Lord
Kings point one thing that I think would
help a lot and again I know Phil is open
to these sort of conversations because
he you know he's he's he very open to
having you know cross-platform stuff
with his competitors I know Sony doesn't
want to do it but imagine if they come
up with something some sort of cross
safe thing where your xbox save can be
used on the switch version of a game the
only portable game in town that it's not
like you'd be you'd be on cannibalizing
your own sales because it'd be two
different versions of the game but the
but a positive to it is that you can you
can play both of them and and you're
sable crossover between both just using
Xbox Live it's just one yeah I mean
that'll you know that'll do something to
alleviate what Kings point is that he
doesn't want to play that game on that
system he must play it at all
exactly no in which this kind of spills
in also to the next point which is on
you know the top as far as the the rumor
that just came out as far as the lead to
achievement so long it looks like there
was a developer bring the Gaza that
they're making a green for the switch
really be uh you have the rest behind is
being like spear so it looks like they
had a nanny on reddit and one user asked
them about you know will this game have
online rankings and instead of the
normal you know like no it's not
you know they officially came out and
kind of spilled the beans then they were
like Nintendo doesn't have an official
support for achievements in leaderboards
yet but like like Sony and Microsoft but
he said we know that they are working on
so this is something that's in
development and hopefully for um you
know when the online system goes live
and I thought that was an interesting
comment the fact that he kind of reveals
something that he shouldn't you know I
guess the did oh my baby I've been ready
to talk about it but they are saying
definitively that online achievements
and leaderboards are this I want to know
what the Lord's felt about that
welcome to the party
yeah to make Lord kiss move Lord addict
you know these are main deterrents for
Xbox fans you know who want to get a
switch in a lot of people are
achievement you know fans and that's a
huge thing look at the leaderboard to
see where your friends are and also if
you just playing a game and just to get
you know some type of recognition for
said thing and there's even been some
games I believe it's the sky or whatever
game they take that the dev still kept
achievements in his own game that he had
from PlayStation he still kept that
format so it I thought it was
interesting monsters what do you feel
about this I mean it's just it's nice to
see I mean if some people really love me
as you said they actually live for just
those achievements they're not always
totally I mean some are kind of useless
some are like five five hundred thousand
you know core exceeds or something like
that it's like you find all 900 it might
be cool platinum right there I swear to
God Nintendo should like find her
address and mail you like they gotta
like send you at least a certificate
like hey we understand we ain't giving
you much but you crushed our game done
what you've 100 percent Zelda which we
didn't think was possible it's no way to
go honestly though what I'd be curious
this season if they do achievements you
wouldn't intend Oh style take something
like you did with splatoon with like
certain things that you've taken and
make it put the spin on it but have some
fun where it's like hey Nintendo did
this like Nintendo surprised this once
again and did it right so oh do
something like that
take their spin on it have a little fun
I don't know I'd like to see what they
could do glad to see it's there though
[Music]
80 bucks in the store and I thought I
was just by the exclusive Joyce oh I
guarantee they fix it because right now
they win it so they look into Lord Kings
point I gotta give them this is also
which is there also big return right now
in it better parties and I want to bring
it real quick is the whole fact that the
cartridges are more expensive and
because we got to dilemma where so then
I was like okay maybe they should just
go download-only but no because they got
the dilemma because of the storage space
like a game like a 2k which is over 25
games out of this stuff it didn't like
you really boxed your user base in like
because they're mandatory now to buy
this and I just think it was to play
your switch you're gonna need a raid
enclosure on your belt
in the beginning he foretold this till
you see the memory so he said yo they
got the make sure that you get the
memory cause he and I said well what's
kind I need
it goes up - no I thought the memory I
mean the Chad thing was stupid
this is stupid I have new drives coming
out there stick drives there like a big
kind of weird metal metal stick that
looks like a piece oh please yeah yeah
20 terabytes those are going up to 20
terabytes you could walk around with
that like it like about 10 inch just
bandage that [ __ ] up and shot themselves
in the other guy
but I bet that we gotta wrap up football
is approaching me at the three minute
mark got fantasy leagues to do I wanna
give a shout out to lordy bonta's we're
coming through talking it Nestle talked
like old times it felt good lordy boxes
waiting to find people find it is a bond
test everywhere so II Bo and T is twitch
TV streaming a lot especially for Disney
to on YouTube trying to enjoy the game
right now but all people in videos out
so I'm blue in the face and of course on
Twitter as well it's a few ends it's on
there but yeah and find me on Yvonne
test everywhere you guys thank you for
support oh isn't honored to be on here
appreciate it guys so besties to blot it
was so legit when I heard what the
topics was this week I said please make
sure you bought this this is the man
check his channel out great great guy
walk through strategies all that good
stuff man he puts out good content and
he's he's been our day one man he's a
little nothing channel
he gave a circle Guardian khan bros our
third exactly we pounded our ale we
talked destiny I was like know that I
got a shovel of so always always a
pleasure in of course shout out the og
Lords today what 0 Lords thought about
they we're gonna find people find you
bullets right now here right yeah much
which account have been running bullets
rain is just bullets underscore rain
that's that's me that's mainly where
I've been I've been playing a lot of
games just hanging out you know it's
just I like live streaming this fun
really we will also won't catch you on
our PC master-race it but their partner
program is a little law intense I don't
know um if you know it might be
something that I do a little on the side
here and there but obviously uh twitches
a little bit more relaxed when it comes
to if they're gonna be if I can be
partnering with people I got a few
friends that have partnered right now so
okay I was I was just considering you
know trying to play a little bit and see
see where I can go with
chickens obviously Twitter's is a you
know something that could happen first
make some wishes a little little rougher
they got you got to be professional like
750 people professional out of time you
know on your on your account
yeah and of course was also pleasure to
have on landlord zero back-to-back og
weeks it was good 0 helping out that
channel 5 clan with those night falls
those rewards I I cashed it in Hawthorne
because of you thank you sir
anyone gonna be on destiny afterwards
Xbox at least I got to run around and
clean up a little bit here but you find
me everywhere i LP make sure next week
to turn into after-hours bar Cadia heads
9 p.m. Central time on Thursday
so now freeze okay shadow the busy shout
the weekly show this week but life is
only think if you make it a thing fight
the good fight that was fun we're gonna
find people find you not playing destiny
with anybody
PSN be examined and Lord saw by OPR
Twitter and of course the premium gamer
himself Lord King
wicked 5 even find you you could catch
me at Instagram Twitter Facebook
rather than the normal stuff listen hit
me up on Twitter to find out more about
the t-shirts also us Lords is trying to
work on some video packaging so you can
see us and you know the Lord's life what
the boys do so we're trying to get that
in you know and a physic for y'all guys
that you know to check that stuff out
man um but I'm gonna be on destiny um so
you know you guys can jump on add me if
you haven't added me King David OTW
it's gonna be on getting it on right now
I'm trying to do this nightfall today so
get ready for that raid then of course
look like neo here again shout out to
the chat everybody was lit shout
everybody who's acknowledging the new
time again we're gonna rock this for a
while during football season 11:00 a.m.
Eastern Standard Time please hit that
like subscribe to the inner circle
Network shout out to all the people who
are still following the iron Lords
podcast YouTube channel I love you guys
but you getting the videos late it's
just the dark guys so please subscribe
to the inner circle network that's what
we partnered with we got nice things
lined up there is also a patreon link in
the description please check that out we
can have more advantages information in
the description and you can also find us
on path being so we have the audio up
there that goes out to all media outlets
audio outlets including iTunes as well
so look for the inner circle network
there for the audio so you guys can get
that and you'll see the iron law podcast
episodes as well so how to tick them all
the support we need helps and we are
about to be out of here so on that note
peace